What a person feels
that someone intensely and consciously manifests
The answer is simple
feels and thinks what you assume
to feel and think
Dats it's the end of discovering
if you assume yourself
that this person often thinks about you
it will be so
if you assume
that this person does not love you
it will be so
if you assume
that this person
I never want anything more to do with you.
Guess what it will be
and it doesn't mean
that it always works
Only in the case of negative assumptions
It always works on the same principle.
Will they be negative or positive assumptions?
but not my fault anymore
Most of us are negative.
and that is why this version of the person experiences
so start positively wearing pleats
plis because this is not a fetter y ym
I have already translated into other films
If you want to see it look on my profile
see you will learn
I myself recently manifested within 30 minutes
Two people wrote me what I wanted.
Why
because they only reflect my assumptions
And I always get what I want
I always get it
what I dream about and everything comes to me quickly
easy and pleasant
that's why everyone in my reality
He always adapts to my expectations.
and always willing to show me
I'm right because that's how the subconscious works.
Jesus Christ and finally the pleats
understand that this is not spontaneous
It's not about bending someone's free will.
Right away I say
for such comments plus the designation
Tarot banning flies straight away
I'm not going to explain why
if you want it please
Welcome to my profile
Where I explain everything
and practically there is an answer to every question
what you can seriously imagine
And if you want to know more
I invite you to my group on facebook
on which there are posts where I explain in detail
This topic debunks myths
refute the pharmahs
before still a very important matter pleats
Answer 3 questions
and in particular the rules
because I don't want any negative energy there
because in my reality it does not exist
Also this good night
Have a nice night and
Anything you want
Fruitful manifestations